let's jump into the actual like main
news and then uh we got a lot of talk
about
so this story is the it's happening from
the daily mail portland police's
entire riot squad resigns after cop was
indicted
for striking activist photographer who
they insist was a rioter
with baton during violent protest saw
government building
set uh government building satellite you
see the portland police union said the
officers would be leaving the squad in
response to the indictment on tuesday
of a member of member corey budworth
bardworth was charged with assault
related to an august 18-20 incident
in which he allegedly struck a
photographer terry jacobs of the baton
the police union said the officers were
set upon by 200 protesters
and that budworth had accidentally hit
jacobs in the head they have also
claimed jacobs was part of the riot
she was not charged with any crime and
was awarded a fifty thousand dollar
settlement by the city of portland over
the incident
despite the resignation the officers
officers would remain employed by the
portland police department
it's not clear how this will affect the
department's ability to respond to riots
you know what i really love how they say
it's the riot squad responding to
protests
yeah can we just say the riot squad
responds to riots yeah yeah
i guess they do respond to protests too
so they're not they're not quitting the
entire department
they just are refusing to go out during
riots anymore
and here's another thing in their
defense is that you see in a lot of
these places they arrest people and then
it's just the revolving door the
prosecutors aren't gonna do anything and
explicitly so so then it's like wait i
gotta get in the middle of this
drama i'm people are gonna be throwing
whatever at me
uh everyone's gonna hate me i'm gonna
arrest this person the person's gonna be
like just
walk right out the door like at the very
least like why am i putting in all this
effort
it's worse than that now and this is
what i love about it i've been going on
uh
people were tweeting at you because i
said abolish the police they were like
michael you've done such great work with
tim
that's true and uh but my my reason for
about the police is
not the same as yours i think okay uh
although i do think definitely
the conversations we've had have been
influential to my opinions as well
i think the reason they should be
leaving is because they can't do their
jobs
functionally anymore i agree it's not so
we agree but you know i think you're
more of the
anarchists the police are bad across the
board i definitely agree with you on the
gun thing for sure that was like a good
a good argument
but what we're seeing now is not only
will the police
if they arrest someone nothing happens
to that person they're actually
arresting the cops now
that's amazing imagine the kind of
feckless
pathetic spineless jellyfish cop you'd
have to be
to turn around and arrest your own cop
who was doing literally what the
what the city told them to do well that
guy's a hero because that means that
those cops were enforcing a
law law should be arrested right so
those guys so then what happens is one
by one they start arresting each other i
i mean i don't i don't know
one by one but in all seriousness like
yeah i
obviously i'm no friend of the police
and i always say and i will defend that
every cop is a criminal
but at a certain point it's just like
you
feel i'm sure the vast majority of
people who are police officers feel all
right it's a tough job
someone's got to do it and i'm really
helping people i'm stopping murders i'm
stopping rapists like little kids are
not getting snatched
yeah it sucks but someone's gotta do it
i'm doing a good job of it at a certain
point
if in any gig like if you had ian here
and you're like ian you can only talk
for 30 seconds every hour it's at a
certain point it's like why am i even
here like
what am i doing here right so it's the
same thing it's like i have this job and
i have my fantasy or my
you know ideal version of what it's
going to be and my boss
is not only not allowing me to do it but
it's taking steps to prevent me to do it
it's just like
how much respect you have for me i'm
getting crapped on by the people the
street i'm gonna crap them on my boss
and my colleagues
how am i gonna have dignity for my home
let's take it one step further
let's say please let's take as many as
possible here's what i mean let's say
you know like luke's luke's joining us
on the show
you know he comes in periodically
imagine if i said here's the only thing
you're allowed to talk about
make it really really difficult for him
and then the then he actually does
what i tell him to do and i get mad
because it just for some reason caused
me a problem so i lock him in the
basement
and you publish no no that's that's
insane and publicly denounce him that's
the other no no no no no
no no no no no no no no i'm serious
because i know these cops names are
public
so that means they're no they're known
in the in by all their neighborhood
that i got arrested for doing my job
that's not going to feel nice well how
dare you equate me to a cop
first of all second of all uh the police
union chief had a very interesting
comment he said our uh rt
rrt members do not volunteer to have
molotov cocktails fireworks explosives
rocks bottles urine feces and other
dangerous objects thrown at them
they do he noted that the team members
volunteer for the work without any
specific
pay so these members are stepping down
out of this response unit the mayor
wheeler asked him please don't do this
don't do this
and and then the police responded well
too bad we're doing this anyway
uh after of course all the you know
major political decisions that have been
happening in portland now now
here's the best part imagine um i asked
luke to come on the show
i then say here's the only thing you're
allowed to say then
even when he just does what i asked i
publicly denounce him
luke instead of quitting the show says
well
i won't talk about foreign policy
anymore and he keeps coming to the show
these cops they're resigning from the
riot squad right
and they're staying with the city
staying under the boot of the corrupt
system
that's literally trying to put a cop in
jail because they sent him out at a riot
i was trying to talk nice about the cops
you're making it harder oh no i i won't
have it man
i've been saying for a while you know
that woman um in in minnesota she shot
the the guy
he was he was a a wanted felon for a gun
charge or armed robbery
what was her name kimberly potter potter
potter yeah this was during the chauvin
trial
she was trying to she she was going for
a taser and then she pulled her gun on
accident
she shoots the guy yeah that's yeah okay
i said i hope good
prison right to prison because
negligence yeah well there's two things
one is
you are responsible for anything that
comes out of your gun period however if
she actually shot him should have been
justified not that i'm happy that it
happened it's a sad tragic story
but he was a wanted fugitive who had a
gun and jumped in his car
the point is as i've described it the
people of minnesota
the officers and of portland are
standing inside
a burning building yeah we've warned
them repeatedly to get out
and in response to a giant beam smacking
one of the cops in the head
they go well we'll stand in the kitchen
instead of the living room it's like
maybe just get out dude
i've got a lot of messages from cops who
have said they were they're they're the
cops that i refer to as the good cops
who got out when they saw how bad it was
getting
and these are the cops who want to save
little kid from getting kidnapped these
are the cops who want to stop the drug
dealers from destroying our
neighborhoods
these are the cops want to make sure
that crime isn't skyrocketing in new
york city
but they can't do it anymore they're
getting targeted they're getting
arrested so they're quitting
and even in the military there's similar
similar things happening with i saw your
face uh michael and i agree with you
because if we look at police if we look
at policing the last few months what
have they been doing they've been
arresting
religious pastors they have been
arresting private businesses they have
been enforcing unconstitutional illegal
decrees of politicians
and destroying people's livelihoods
while protecting the billionaire class
the nypd the florida police department
prosecutors judges the fbi intelligence
agencies
all looked the other way for 30 years
when it came to children being hurt in
the most unspeakable ways
with a mr epstein so so there's a lot of
you know discontent to bring up there
especially with what's happening in
canada right now where there was a
horrible video of a pastor being
arrested in front of his children
maxine bernay was just arrested for
hosting a political rally
right now the police in canada are
absolutely out of control and
and i do believe we need to strike a
balance but we need to have an honest
conversation
that's not just one-sided on the issue
they've been there been a lot of
problems with cops for a very very long
time
but let's just keep in mind the stuff
we're seeing over the past year and into
now
a lot of the cops you'd probably like
have left i i was looking at my phone
because a cop messaged me and he said
because of your work i'm quitting the
force and i'm mailing you my badge and
i'm going to private security
and i wanted to give him a shout out
which maybe i'll look for it later but
it's very kind of moving that uh i
even for one person that he's like okay
i i at the very least even if you're
gonna stay in the force
acknowledge what it is that you're doing
like i can even wrap my head around okay
i'm violating the constitution and i'm
disarming people but it's for a greater
good fine like i could wrap my head
around that
i i told this story before when when i
went and was getting my first gun the
gun shop in jersey said they had a big
problem where a woman
so if you live in the south jersey area
you're
10 minutes from philadelphia you crossed
the bridge you're in philadelphia
in pennsylvania you're allowed to bear
arms like very really great
good laws not perfect well a woman was
armed legally
and she was going to atlantic city
didn't look up the laws in new jersey
she made that mistake
cop actually arrested her on a felony
charge it's like why would the cop do
that
why wouldn't the cops say ma'am you are
not allowed to have this weapon here in
new jersey i'm going to escort you back
to the bridge you made a mistake i
understand please leave
take your gun home to where it's legal
for you to keep come back to my state
without that weapon
instead he's just like oh boy i got one
you're going to prison lady
i'm thinking about what you said about
abolish the police i'm wondering and
correct me if i'm wrong if what you're
what you're really saying what you saw
what you're saying is
got one out did you see i did i loved
every minute
cathy newman jordan peterson himself
shout out to kathy
but that you're suggesting that police
boycott the department or
strike on the department if it's corrupt
yes
not abolish the entire system so
it's almost a little bit more nuanced
but that is that is just the point
the other thing i'm saying is if the
police force is becoming more and more
corrupt
and some would argue especially black
lives matter and antifa and even ant
caps anarchists on the right any of any
capacity
that they've been corrupt for a very
very long time notably michael i don't
like that word corrupt here
because i think they're not being
dishonest i think they're just being
forced through politics to do things in
a certain way
so so i'll put it this way if the police
are no longer serving the interests of
the public let's do that yeah
then why would i want to fund
something that causes harm to good
people if you're a cop
and you want a better society to be a
hero to help
then you need to reconcile one very
important circumstance
black lives matter and antifa have been
smashing up buildings and destroying
setting fires and these people are not
going to jail but
if i choose to keep and bear arms in
some ridiculous
twisted rule come if it comes into play
the cops will arrest me for that so if
you look at chicago for example
mandatory minimums often right so it's
not like you're going to get off that
it's like it was your first time with
innocent mistakes like that judge has to
sentence you often
yep so this is the law so the cops need
to understand
even if i've had cops message me saying
look we just arrest law breakers
it's the it's the da's you're mad at and
i said no
if you personally know this and you do
because you're emailing me and you watch
the show
that the district attorneys you are go
if you know
that if you arrest one antifa and one
conservative
and send them both the da and the da
laughs and sends the antifa on his way
and then welcomes the conservative into
prison for bearing arms
you are the one delivering people to
prison
and you can and the officers can make
the choice to say
like i said with the new jersey lady
look lady ma'am you got a good cop right
here
i'm going to escort you back to the
bridge it's a 10-minute drive you're
going to go home you're going to leave
that gun otherwise some other state
trooper is going to lock you up and i
don't want to see that happen no he
didn't
he just said man you're under arrest the
story was he pulls her over
and she did the right thing officer i am
armed i just we just
just want to let you know and he goes
right away man please step out of the
vehicle it's she gets up put your hands
behind your back
is something wrong ma'am quiet hands
behind your back arrest her you're under
arrest it's illegal it's a felony to
carry that weapon in new jersey
that's it and she freaks out she's
panicked some middle-aged woman going to
go to the casino and have a good time
broke no laws was legally bearing i
should say constitutionally bearing her
arm
but in new jersey they say it's
statutorily illegal and the cop had no
problem
sending a middle-aged woman into the
prison system fortunately i was
traumatic
the nra apparently got involved and then
made a big stink
and the d.a dropped the charges and told
her not to do it again but they don't do
that for people in inner city chicago
for young black men
who want to protect themselves because
there's gang violence i got no sympathy
for somebody who wants to join gang
violence what about the old black ladies
who are going to be left in new york
city when everyone moves out and who are
in the projects who can't afford to move
absolutely lauren chen who you guys have
had on who i adore
uh you know sometimes someone just says
one sentence that's kind of just light
bulbs you and
just rattles you from she's incredible
she's the best she was on my show was
one of
hers i remember and she was having an
issue in canada because her dad had
cancer yes and for like a year he
couldn't even get like a scan it was
something absolutely crazy
and she just goes why am i funding my
own oppression
and i was like holy like you like learn
you like nailed it and it's the kind of
thing where it's just like
yeah why am i paying these high taxes in
these cities
so the cops can leave me unsafe in my
own home
where i can't have a gun to protect
myself which is my god-given
constitutional right and none of your
business
right that's it i mean while you guys
are ginning up as much unrest and burn
it all down as possible at the same time
so so my my issue is i'm in new jersey
i had a cop actually tell me to go buy a
gun because someone tried breaking in
and then i looked up the law and they're
like if the guy did break in
and you did shoot him you go to prison
yeah welcome yeah
and i'm like what he broke into my house
though and like we should have left
like where am i supposed to go it's my
house it's a big house like am i no no
this is back in jersey
small house okay yeah small oh it was
all okay
five bedroom but am i supposed to just
go jump my fence in my backyard and go
stand in the middle of the street
in my underwear you're supposed to die
and be a statistic
and then they could say look we're we're
fighting gun violence is an all-time
high we need more cops
right that's what laurie lifefoot is
doing right now her emails were also uh
leaked recently and people are finding
the true picture of who she really was
but places like chicago and new york
city have absolutely atrocious
self-defense laws where even
if you get attacked first you defend
yourself you cause any mark or harm to
the perpetrator you go to jail no matter
what the situation no matter what the
circumstance and these officers don't
care
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you